[Music]
you think so huh
i mean if you're stepping it makes a lot
of sense from the most successful
company in the history of companies
yep there's no reason for you to step
down
there's nothing going on your life is
easy you got a divorce
you're tagging this new chick you got
way more money
after the divorce everything has worked
out perfectly for you
yeah everybody seems to love amazon
despite the fact that it's clearly a
monopoly yeah but you've convinced the
american public that it's not
because we're getting [ __ ] for cheap
even free fans
your competition super free super fast
matter of fact
thank you for the wallpaper killed it
with that
that maui leaf is it maui leaves now we
leave maui leaf
you even had enough for mark's shirt i
made a whole button down out of the wall
get him mark i thought we were going to
australia
he had no clue that miami dundee over
here
that's what you call a knife wait a
minute
wait a minute it is you're going up
point is
bezos is stepping down from amazon and i
can't think of any other reason besides
he think there thinks there's going to
be a vacancy
in well no he thinks there's going to be
a potential not a vacancy but he'd think
there's going to be potential for
another outsider
to win the presidency i love him i'm not
even a big bezos guy but i love it
you need to run the government like a
cutthroat company
do you though i don't know if you do i
kind of think you
don't i think the are you sure that's
literally what trump did
trump was like i'm just gonna support
the people who buy things at my business
and then half the country was like we
don't like that
my brain freaked out because it sounded
like you were making a good point you
just kind of stopped thinking for a
second yeah yeah but here's what i'm
saying
wait was that a good point i don't know
it sounded you pointed the knife at me i
was i
got flustered everyone's like nice
non-white son it's so much fun talk
about a point you pointing a point but
i'm just saying like
usually you know what happens if you
smash them together does it make the
well let's try let's go oh that's a
knife
that [ __ ] is fired real
yo if you're listening to this podcast
step your game up bro
i mean i mean don't stop because those
are great too but also youtube
you get to see all this the new set you
might see dove's foot pop into the wide
every once in a while we haven't given
him a camera just yet though he might be
earning his keep the point being
i mean he offered up his sisters to be
on the podcast and his own
mother beautiful woman beautiful woman
for the limelight
i would even say stunning really thank
you i would even say
put them on screen i would even say a
smoke a show
[Music]
okay i would never say that i did
do you think bezos could run and do you
think that's what he's planning for
here's what i was trying to get the
point i was getting to if you've seen
government like anybody works a
government job
they get nothing done it's the least
efficient thing on earth government
programs completely inefficient they pay
the least of course
tax money gets used so inefficiently i
think you need a corporate guy to be
like hey let's let's fix all this [ __ ]
and a corporate guy who's already made
all their money yeah the reason why you
often don't have talent in the public
sector is because those people go to the
private sector and they make ten times
the amount of money
right why would i organize the dmv when
i could be organizing or i could be
doing consulting for some crazy bill
just sell
cars and make billions of dollars boom
100 i still
think that bezos has realized i've made
all the money i can make
i've done everything i can do okay i've
divorced my wife
and made it back oh yeah once you
divorce your wife
yeah and you make it back and then some
you think you're unstoppable it took
like a calendar year it didn't even take
time
one pain he started one pandemic right
dude what if he started the pandemic he
was like [ __ ] you thought
i think that's what the move was i would
love a bezos trump election or bezos
cuban election i mean then she would be
so lit
bezos and cuban going at it i just think
it's interesting to see him step away
i don't know i think anyone that has a
ton of money sees trump and goes it's
not worth it
so like they got a little i think they
all think i think it's the opposite i
think they have such egos they say i
could do that better
maybe he could howard schultz thought he
did
could but cornball duck
[ __ ] cornbread he's bird horn ball
corn this is the starbucks
cornball starbucks dog seattle get out
of here you cuck
[ __ ] nerd i care about the people
i was like a great show
now that we updated is [ __ ] starbucks
coffee bean all day eat a dang a lamb
that's what i'm talking about let's go
say it like that
boy
[Laughter]
have you had these cappuccinos i mean
this guy's amazing man
but if you're right on if you're right
on bezos
who are the two people that won covid
besos for the democrats
and on the right side who could win
governor of florida
oh fantastic just finna get that
[ __ ] right that would be if you
want to talk about some
a political insider that could do it
it's desantis now desantis is governor
where do you go from governor
el presidente it's the only president
so desantis i think he got a shot i
think that um
bezos is definitely going to go for it i
think he's got nothing to lose he's
already got the whole scandal out about
his wife
and the fact that trump had four wives
yeah it don't matter it doesn't matter
anymore none of this [ __ ] matters
anymore the morality of it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter for the dems
either
no i think the dems have been exposed as
well i think people i think they're just
like
okay we voted for biden because
he was the lesser of two evils exactly
so we're willing
to absolve these political figures for
their
you know uh past transgressions be them
political or
you know i i guess personal it's okay as
long as they're not as bad as the other
guys so all you gotta do is paint the
other guys worse they'll vote
yeah you think these dems are gonna stop
using amazon [ __ ] no nope
yeah and the republicans aren't i'm
trying to find the words for this but
trump said a lot of things that made him
unelectable to
anybody on the left then we elect biden
and now we're at war with afghanistan
two weeks in son what is biden
like do people care does anybody care
about anything like
i i feel like the right wing news should
be
sticking everything to biden but
nobody's even talking about it that's
good yeah
keep going no no but what does that say
like i think no news is good news
yes but is does that mean that the
establishment is kind of on the same
side regardless
like they could i think didn't biden say
two thousand dollars is coming
no there's no more two thousand dollars
that's been walked back hey we're not
gonna
intervene in the middle east anymore
we're going right back out there yeah i
got a plan for the
coronavirus there's nothing there's no
plan fossil fuels i'm not going to touch
your fossil fuels we're not going to do
any more federal fracking
right this is every election this is
every president of course but i guess
what i'm saying is like
the news in the way that the news was
reacting to trump and it was actually
really successful in their reaction
right regardless if like
fox news is on trump's side or not it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it's just they
were getting [ __ ] ratings by slamming
the other side
yeah the right-wing news organizations
have fodder
to slam and it feels like they're not
yeah i kind of
feel if i had to assume i think it's
just the way biden's going about it
because like with the fossil fuel
situation he's like
he's uh trying to make up the jobs that
are gonna be lost so he's like yeah
we're moving away from fossil fuels but
i'm gonna put programs in place where uh
re-job training and [ __ ] like that so
it's kind of like hey i'm not just going
change some [ __ ] like trump did like
once he walked in and you got to deal
with it i'm going to be like all right
i'm about to make some changes and i'm
going to try to make it
work for everybody great point my only
concern is that usually the news doesn't
care about context
usually they're going to go off the most
salacious line but great point
i just wonder if because biden is part
of the establishment
both parts of the political news aisle
are just going
thank god let's just get [ __ ] back to
normal calm [ __ ] down
to the bezos point though what i think
hope kind of might happen
is people are like all right cool once
we see that it's just back to politics
as normal no matter who we elect
outside of the outsider i want an
outsider i just don't want one as
divisive
and that's where bezos cuban all those
guys to me
hit that middle swath of america that's
like nah i [ __ ] with this guy he's
different but he's not divisive who
could not vote for bezos
like that's the thing yeah even bernie
in them right like
bernie and them are saying 15 minimum
wage
so is amazon now amazon is doing it to
put pressure
on their mom and pop competitors because
the mom and pops can't pay 15 but amazon
definitely can and they're also
replacing them with the robotic
workforce
of course exactly they're going to have
much less work for it so whoever is
there will pay 15
of course but if you're a 15 minimum
wage loyalist like the super left people
are
they're satisfying it if you're right
wing this is
capitalism on steroids i i cannot fathom
either side even the extremes of those
sides
objecting to bezos yeah this is american
industry he's not
i don't think in any way he's like cow
towing to china i think extreme left
would still hate him because he's so
capitalist but moderate they would
they would don't get me wrong they'd
find a way but he is still checking off
some of their boxes i don't i don't
think he's running
i think maybe something's coming down
the line where it's like
he needs to separate himself or it could
have come [ __ ] with
amazon or something to save yeah i agree
yeah i think that's what's coming what
do you think it is
how much you know how they were trying
to like break up these big
organizations and [ __ ] like that and you
know how he like the majority of their
money comes from
that website you could be onto something
what if it's a legacy play what if it's
i'm to get
out of my company before it's broken up
because i don't want to be the guy yeah
i think that's brilliant i don't want to
be the guy
seated in that position and watch it
it's not going to crumble but watch it
not become
fractured yes and i understand that if
if you're at this point you have this
much money
and all you're concerned about is legacy
um i'm out
you can only go down from here position
right now now he gets to go back to blue
origin
his spaceship he get he's i used to see
him at all he goes to every event for
amazon prime and
wants to spend money for the content
right he wants to now compete with
netflix amazon's doing
great with original content yes they are
he's got things to do
it's it's crazy and a little bit scary
how big and good all these companies are
at everything
like spacex uh spacex is also tesla
which is they're going out of space and
then they're gonna do solar paneling and
that's gonna be even bigger than the
cars
google is gonna make a [ __ ] they make
cell phones start as an internet
provider
god knows what else they're going to do
self-driving cars like they're just
these companies are making everything
was it you that said it
about uh apple the apple car
no the miles that they're poaching uh
yeah they got like this top engineer
from porsche yeah so apple was going for
it
only way now all these companies aren't
even competing within their sector
they're competing with the other giants
okay do you think that the reason why
bezos was able to step down is because
elon took over
the number one spot